boa noite já é noite né é realmente
muito empolgante estar aqui
compartilhando tantos sentidos e meu
convite pra vocês hoje é imaginar o
sentido da liberdade na educação
a educação é freqüentemente associada ao
desenvolvimento e não sem razão
pesquisas demonstram que quanto mais
anos de escolaridade uma pessoa tem mais
e melhores empregos ela terá essa mesma
ideia pode ser aplicada para países e
populações
agora a gente não precisa ficar preso
numa perspectiva apenas e econômica do
desenvolvimento
em 1998 o indiano chamado amartya sen
ganhou o prêmio nobel de economia ele
foi o primeiro não nascido em países
considerados desenvolvidos a ganhar essa
premiação amartya sen defende a
perspectiva que o desenvolvimento pode
ser um processo de expansão das nossas
liberdades reais das liberdades reais
que as pessoas experimentam isso quer
dizer que mais do que dinheiro que poder
econômico importa a capacidade das
pessoas decidirem por si mesmas a
capacidade delas controlar o destino de
suas vidas
e essa perspectiva é muito interessante
porque daí a liberdade
além de um fim do desenvolvimento passa
a ser um meio para alcançá-lo empoderada
as pessoas livres
elas conseguem fazer melhor julgamentos
e escolher melhor e construir uma
sociedade mais satisfatória para si
mesmo e para aqueles que os rodeiam
só que me chama muita atenção e na
verdade me espanta é perceber que a
educação está associado ao
desenvolvimento e o desenvolvimento pode
ser visto como liberdade
por que há tão pouca liberdade ao longo
da história na educação
alguns meses atrás
aliás é um pouco mais de um ano e com
essa vitória
vitória adolescentes baiana que estuda
no colégio odorico tavares aqui no
centro de salvador
tal como o vitória muitos e muitos
adolescentes não podem escolher na sua
relação com o processo de aprendizagem o
seu próprio processo de aprendizagem
eles não podem escolher o que vão
estudar não podem escolher com quem vão
estudar quando vão estudar nem mesmo
como vão estudar já recebe da escola um
programa pronto e definido estudam 200
dias letivos organizados em semanas e
cinco dias
eles não podem escolher com quem estudar
estudam com pessoas de uma mesma série
em geral que têm a ver com faixa etária
ou seja não podem nem ter a companhia
daqueles mais novos nem aproveitar a
experiência dos mais velhos
os meninos e as meninas vitória outros
colegas não podem escolher como estudar
parece aquele programa fala que eu te
escuto
só que no caso o professor fala e apenas
os estudantes apenas escutam
essa falta de liberdade
essa falta de conexão com o processo
educativo dificulta a criação de
vínculos com esse próprio processo
educativo dos estudantes
quem aqui nunca sentiu que a escola não
fazer sentido para sua vida
quem é que nunca se perguntou por que
tem tão pouca ingerência sobre o
processo que é seu portanto o que eu
posso fazer aqui pra vocês aqui
diferente de muitos adolescentes jovens
ao redor do mundo no brasil
o vitória teve a oportunidade de
conhecer o centro juvenil de ciência e
cultura
pra não ficar assim com muitos e muitos
estudantes
o sepe vitória pra mim é enorme
satisfação passa boa parte de suas
tardes lá o centro juvenil ciência e
cultura são escolas laboratórios são
invenções genuinamente baianas e
brasileiras que ajudei a conceber na
secretaria estadual de educação
existem cinco centros juvenis em toda a
bahia
o primeiro criado aqui em salvador que é
pertinho e nazaré no colégio central foi
criado em 2013
o segundo em senhor do bonfim e depois
tivemos entre juvenis em itabuna vitória
da conquista e barreiras
o centro vem de salvador e senhor do
bonfim fazem parte do mapa da inovação e
criatividade da educação básica
esse mapa foi elaborado pelo ministério
da educação em 2013 e eu ouso dizer pra
vocês que se fosse hoje todos os cinco
centros juvenis fariam parte desse mapa
temos 150 cv e um mapa e até então nove
mil alunos de toda a bahia se
matricularam no centro juvenis e 15 mil
pessoas fizeram parte das atividades
pedagógicas proporcionadas por nós
quando decidi ir para o centro juvenil
o estudante faz uma decisão que é
exclusivamente dele
a participação é voluntária ele vai se
ele quiser
e essa decisão gente a gente considera
que é uma apropriação de seu processo de
aprendizagem é uma escolha do estudante
e quando eles escolhem quando eles
resolvem participar do centro juvenil
aí sim eles percebem que eles têm um
leque enorme de escolhas podem fazer com
uma câmera que estuda o que interessa
ela decidiu participar da oficina
chamada recicla e e ressignifica
materiais que seriam simplesmente
transformados em lixo pela sociedade
pode fazer também como a bruna que
atravessa salvador inteira sai de
mussurunga para o centro da cidade
quase todas as tardes para estudar com
sua equipe de robótica pode ainda fazer
como duda que aproveita a sombra do
flamboyant de barreiras
simplesmente pra ler um livro
várias e várias tardes a fio no centro
de verniz os estudantes podem escolher
quando estudar eles podem estudar de
acordo com seu compra de comprometimento
pode estudar uma tarde duas tardes ou
muitas tardes
vinícius aqui é incrível coleção de 15
certificados não cabe na mão 15
certificados do centro imagina quantas
tardes quando as manhãs quantas noites
ele pode ter passado lá e ele escolheu
isso nos centros
os estudantes não podem escolher com
quem estudar mas eles não ficam presos a
uma série a uma faixa etária como eu
fiquei com muitos de vocês ficaram pode
e pode acontecer o que aconteceu com
gabriel que hoje está na faculdade mas
ele teve a oportunidade de ensinar
técnicas de vôo na aula de piloto
virtual aqui em salvador
para muitos e muitos jovens mais novos
que ele uma das coisas que eu mais gosto
do centro juvenil é que ele pode
escolher o estudante pode escolher a
estudante pode escolher como estudar
pode montar uma banda pode fazer um
experimento científico pode optar por
fazer investigações próprias ou fazer
como tiago filipe luis
eles programaram um game chamado choices
um jogo sobre nutrição esse jogo levou
os meninos para salvador para belo
horizonte fez com que eles ganharam
homenagem da câmara de vereadores da
sociedade que é vitória da conquista e
fez com que eles ganharem ganhassem até
5 mil reais
uma premiação de um edital sobre
educação e tecnologia
omara a professora desses meninos que
orientou o game
ela é hoje considerada a melhor
professora de ensino médio do estado da
bahia pelo prêmio profissionais da
educação
nós temos uma relação tão emblemática
com a liberdade no centro de um verniz
que botamos abaixo fazemos questão de
botar abaixo muros que transforma as
escolas em prisões no lugar a gente
coloca grades estilizadas que permitem
que os dotes vejam e sejam vistos
permitem criar uma transparência e uma
relação orgânica com a comunidade onde
essas escolas estão mas a idéia de
aprendizado não está presa a um cubículo
quadrado muito menos o edifício da
escola
por isso nós
temos estudantes que simplesmente saem
para explorar a fauna ea flora local
no na oficina trilhas do cerrado por
exemplo no município de barreiras ou
pega um trem e vão conhecer a missão do
sahy que é um distrito que deu origem à
cidade de senhor do bonfim
a gente pode até explorar o seu espaço
como aqui em salvador que os meninos só
construíram narrativas simplesmente
usando um aplicativo de chat zap essa
lembra de vitória
olha aqui de novo essa menina junto com
esses sete outros estudantes eles fazem
parte de um grupo de bolsistas parte de
um termo de cooperação entre o centro
juvenil de ciência e cultura ea escola
bahiana de medicina ele gente são da
educação básica e pesquisam com pessoas
pesquisadores de mestrado e doutorado na
universidade na escola bahiana de
medicina
eu quero dizer isso tudo porque esses
rostos todos eles todos esses rostos que
vocês viram durante a apresentação os
envolvidos engajados
eles querem dizer uma coisa e essa coisa
é a escola essa escola por qual estão
passando faz sentido pra mim e faz
sentido em muitos sentidos sentido
porque ela se conecta com a vida deles
porque lá aprender é divertido pode e
deve ser divertido e lá eles escolhem
está é lá que eles escolhem está
portanto a gente pode até se perguntar o
que é uma rede de cinco centros juvenis
pode ter de influência de impacto em uma
rede de educação de 1200 escolas quer do
estado da bahia
ela pode ter um impacto como provocação
para que escolas e professores
percebam a liberdade como um elo
fundamental no processo de aprendizagem
dos seus estudantes e incorporem cielo
no seu dia d
e como os estudantes percebem que são
mais importante de tudo percebe o centro
juvenil uma das muitas pesquisas que nós
fazemos
a gente viu esse depoimento eu me sinto
livre aqui disposta a fazer o que gosto
isso me deixa feliz é um ambiente
acolhedor inovador aqui viva as melhores
experiências muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]